moment just a few seconds ago stephen
curry going over to aaron
showtime taylor and some very
nice words and then more importantly
when you score 38 normally you're gonna
be the player of the game and be the
interview but steph let's step aside for
aaron taylor for a second
tell us man you knocked the intros out
of the park
what was it like being the pa announcer
for the warriors tonight
hey man this is uh like i keep saying
this is surreal
um
i love it i love it i mean we know your
story aaron
getting out of san quentin developing
that relationship with the warriors
killing it
in terms of how you handled all the
courtside games with the warrior
executives
and to be out and have served your time
and to have this great opportunity and
make the most of it
i mean this is hollywood man this is
this is you just season your moment
nice i mean i worked hard you know
in 26 years to rehabilitate myself
and uh in the process of doing that i
just embraced
um the attitude that i could be more
than what i was
you know and once i embraced the
attitude that i could be more than what
i was
then it was time for me to tell other
people you can be more than what you
think you are
that's right